[Musique]
la seule chose dont les gens parlent
aujourd'hui c'est clark la comète a fait
un élève clark et la une des médias
grosse info je vois pas clark
il est peut-être en train de dormir papa
lé plus gros fragment de la comète clark
vont très bientôt entrer dans notre
atmosphère
tout à fait et il ya un choix de fortes
charges si je pense que le spectacle
soit d'impressionnant ou est ce qu'il
voit
jean sérère un des premiers morceaux va
s'écraser s'écraser un petit morceau et
ce sera dans l'océan 2 non mais regardez
sa as
eh ben ça a pas explosé
[Musique]
nous venons d'apprendre que le fragment
vient de percuter le centre de la
floride
attendez il va y en avoir encore
d'autres
allez viens on se regarde nous y allions
deux jours ils ont dit des conneries il
y aura d'autres fragments qui vont
détruire la terre les agences spatiales
part d'une possible extradition
on va affronter ça ensemble ok le grand
faut juste qu'on trouve un refuge
[Musique]
des avions militaires volver des bunkers
au groenland c'est notre seule chanson
rochus
à l'état
oui papa on veut trouver le plus gros
fragment de clark va s'écraser dans
moins de vingt quatre heures je le jure
je vais conduire de famille dans ce bout
car j'en suis sûr frustrant
si vous entendez ce message chercher un
refuge immédiatement qu'est-ce qu'il ya
qu est ce qui se passait j'entendais ce
message ait ratifié
accroche toi
immédiat c'est de chercher un refuge
immédiatement